is there any place in the world that you
still want to go to or is it or is it or
just like yeah what's what's on
everyone's like country or is it all
just downhill from here like i've been
everywhere i want to
there's nowhere else i want to go okay
not really here's the thing right
because people people
like say oh i want to go here over here
like there's some countries people like
i really want to go here i'm like
why why the [ __ ] would you want to go
there yeah they're like like what
i'm not not going to know anything
examples this is going to sound [ __ ]
terrible right there are some countries
right
where it's like not going to lie if i
want a vacation somewhere
i want to know that i can [ __ ] in a
clean toilet okay
i'm just going to say right is that a
bad thing am i allowed to say that
that's a very privileged thing that's
right i know it is but at the end of the
day i'm just going to be honest i don't
want to [ __ ] [ __ ] in the hole in the
ground man it's
okay no too much you never get used to
it
have you ever had to use the hole in the
ground [ __ ] toilet france i had to and i
thought i thought this was a
[ __ ] civilized country what is this i
don't know okay this is like
because i used to go camping so much so
like shooting in a hall was just normal
for me because right
oh i i spoke to alan uh yeah and and
sure when he comes on the podcast you
can tell about it yeah
tell us stories about how his dad forced
him to go to kenya on holiday oh yeah
yeah
and he made it sound out like it was
[ __ ] hell and i'm like
why the [ __ ] would i want to go on
vacation there
when everything sounds horrible like
what
like if i vacation all i want to do is
just relax and just
chill out yeah i don't want to [ __ ]
do activities i don't want to [ __ ]
write it i'm like
i don't want to [ __ ] be uncomfortable
everyone everyone has my granddad
honestly i'm i'm already accepted that i
am like a 60 year old white dude when it
comes to like
you just don't want to like adventure in
another country all right i don't either
i'm 100 with connor in this i'm fine
with doing an activity on a day or two
you know
maybe we can hide but i do not want to
[ __ ] do [ __ ] every day
i also don't want to have to like i
don't want to have pressure
that i need to go see something yes if
if i'm in a place and i'm just like you
need to go here you need to go there you
need to see this i'm just like i hate it
already
like i i will go i will go to one cool
place and i'm
and it's just like i've seen enough i'm
satisfied can i just go home and just
like
[ __ ] enjoy a pine or something that's
that's my that's my perfect
holiday and it doesn't come from a place
maybe it does come from a place of
privilege i don't [ __ ] yeah probably
does but
i honestly don't give a [ __ ] i just want
to chill on my heart
i think it's just because of like what i
went through as a kid because when when
you go on holiday as a kid right
you got to follow what everyone else is
right and you i always had
i always like had this [ __ ]
especially if i go into like a big group
like this stacked [ __ ] itinerary
well all i wanted to do was just stay in
my [ __ ] hotel room and play my
nintendo ds
that's all i wanted to [ __ ] do on
holidays dude cause we used to i used to
go camping
uh uh in france like i said every year
for three weeks
right and i in most years i [ __ ]
hated it
yeah and my parents thought that i was
just like they thought it you know okay
i get it now what they think they're
like oh he's just saying he hates it
yeah you know what i mean like
he's just that's not no no i actually
hated it like
it was like you were in a tent you were
sleeping on the floor it was
uncomfortable so it's like three weeks
you're eating the same [ __ ] like
everything okay so everything is grilled
on a barbie i love i love
camping don't get me wrong i used like
my dad used to take me camping like in
the [ __ ] australian outback like
all the time but it wasn't for three
weeks it was like tops like five days
that's the thing right i think
three weeks is way too i think that's
what like has completely put me off
vacationing in any places that aren't
just like honestly just like relaxing in
a nice bed yeah yeah
just eating nice food like that kind of
like put me off for life because i spent
most of my childhood summers just
sleeping on the floor
eating everything that had to be grilled
that's all you had to cook right
it was a grill baguettes nonstop
and then always always those horrible
public showers that are never clean
and then sometimes you would see like
piss in the corner and it would always
smell and it was just awful
like everything was awful and even as a
12 year old i could be like
i'm is this some peasant joke i'm too
rich to understand right like i i just i
don't know like i
i really like that that would throw me
off i would always be like at home
we had a toilet that was nice and it
didn't stink of
just everything why does it here i i
also wonder how different my perceptions
of a lot of these activities would be
if i actually went nowadays now i would
love to
with my mates because three weeks like
yeah yeah part of part of the reason i
like look back and dread about it is
because you spent it with you were
forced to be there
with like your family and something and
you wanted to do something else that
your family didn't want to do
and i feel like that's just like that
that kind of memory has been ingrained
into me that i just like
i hate this activity because i did that
[ __ ] as a kid and i hated it yeah
because my parents were obsessed with
like
maximizing the [ __ ] out of the day like
it was like yeah
let's let's go if we get in france it's
like yeah let's just walk around this
town all day and i'm like [ __ ]
no i want to go to the arcade all day i
don't i do not want to walk all day
like i'm starting the age where walking
just hurts
all day right i don't know like for some
reason when you're when you're a kid
like walking long distances just doesn't
work like
were you an active kid 100 percent like
yeah i was doing sports two three times
a week oh okay
but for some reason just walking when i
had to walk all day
it was just pain which is pain man
and then and then when you're a kid
right there's nothing more boring than
fishing
um i would have to do it that's true and
i thought i'm glad my dad never got me
into fishing like my dad [ __ ]
described
something that i could see me enjoying
now with a mate and drinking a friend
i've actually been fishing for the first
time recently which is like two years
ago with uh
sydney's dad and sydney's uh brother
took me fishing for the first time
i actually really [ __ ] enjoyed it
right right an adult it's one of those
things that like as a kid
you're just not wired yeah okay okay
they're it's gonna make me sound so bad
but there is one big difference
about why i can enjoy it now versus what
i could enjoy as a kid
and that's because alcohol is now on
yeah yeah
i have never seen a man fish with not a
beer in that little pocket
yeah yeah it just doesn't happen because
i mean it's not part of the charm
yeah right like going it as a kid it is
just like it's the adhd simulator
because
all you want to do is like why is there
enough fish catching on this immediately
yeah oh
i'm trying to get this [ __ ] thing on
the thing of my [ __ ] yeah where's my
nintendo ds i need to [ __ ] cookie
mama for 20 minutes
relax you're trying to do it and nothing
happens
you get [ __ ] fish and as a kid you're
like let's let's kill it and eat it
let's let's do something let's [ __ ]
[ __ ] decapitate this fish
and then that your dad's like we throw
it back here yeah what's the point
i want to eat it you know because you're
a kid and you think
in every video game i've caught it and
i've eat it yeah why are you stopping me
daddy it's the worst activity for a kid
it doesn't make sense and just the whole
thing just
completely ruined like doing that kind
of stuff for me as an adult now because
i have no interest
yeah yeah i i would actually go back
fishing with my mates because it was
just like a nice mail we should go
fishing
we should [ __ ] go fishing with you
i will tell you what because i've had
this image of what fishing would be like
my entire life
and because like my only my only
experience with fishing
my entire life has been through the
[ __ ] fishing mini games you get in
every [ __ ]
every [ __ ] zelda game or every like
it's in animal crossing whatever you
play for the free controller yeah yeah
yeah exactly and i thought to myself
there's no way it's gonna be like this
and i was [ __ ] surprised at how
accurate that simulation is
like it literally felt like a controller
rumble and i'm just like
oh like this is just like the [ __ ]
video game it's
like where's the a button yeah yeah yeah
it's literally just instead of tapping
the a button you just go shh
and yeah it's but for some reason it was
just like it was like very therapeutic
and uh if you like fishing fishing mini
games it's exactly like that and i was
surprised
every like fishing enthusiast is just
like frothing at the bathroom like how
[ __ ] dare he say that
man yeah i don't know man i just it's
completely like
so to answer your question jerry oh god
sorry uh
no i mean there's not really any other
countries that i'm like desperate to go
obviously i want to i still
haven't ever been to any of asia so i
really want to explore asia yeah
like is there a country that's at the
top of your bucket list right now for
like visiting korea
korea korea korea yeah i really want to
go to south korea for me it's iceland
iceland yeah yeah i don't know i love
everything about that country the
language the
just the culture around i'm like all the
places i've seen
because it's such a tiny country right
so it's like if you have a car
you could [ __ ] and you have a week
you could probably visit most of that
country i do want to go mexico but a lot
of people i know who are mexican who are
like uh yeah it's dangerous as far as
yeah yeah that's not what i've heard
i'm like oh okay yeah i really like how
safe it is here
exactly exactly like it's like it's like
food's amazing
really good time yeah it's really
[ __ ] dangerous yeah yeah exactly
is there one for you do you have like a
[ __ ] list of like yeah i only got it
i mean probably iceland is at the top i
do want to really go back to career as
well
yeah korea i i i've heard of enough like
a few days but i feel like that just
wasn't enough time for me yeah i'd love
to go yeah it's highlighted it's just
the stones are away
right like i really want to go thailand
as well oh yeah i definitely want to go
to southeast asia more yeah yeah i want
to i want to go to vietnam as well
you've never been to singapore either or
malaysia or any i've ever been anywhere
in asia except for japan
yeah so i really want to be like i i
want to travel more around asia because
i feel like there's
only a few asian countries that i
haven't visited 2020
yeah trash taste south asian tour
like i mean i i do want to visit just
everywhere really and just make my own
you know i i joke and say i just that i
don't want to go to a lot of places but
i wouldn't mind going and passing
through and checking it out you know
like egypt i really want to go to
algeria i really want to go to um
australia i really want to go to
australia south africa i really want to
go to
yeah um you know and i i was joking
about kenya but
you know i'm sure i could have a nice
time there and i'm just being ignorant
as [ __ ] i really wanna know there's
gonna be comments saying that i am
oh yeah of course because like i've i've
always thought like i don't really wanna
like visit like
this place like africa for instance or
like you know the middle east and stuff
like that but like the more i kind of
hear about those places from people
who are either from there or just from
[ __ ] you see it's just like yeah you
know what
that actually might be kind of dope i
don't know but it's just it's such a
toss up though because there there's a
lot of those countries we just hear
nothing about yeah right and you're just
like is it
are we hearing nothing about it because
it's it's bad or because people just
don't go australia's like a country you
don't hear much about but it's pretty
nice i really like austria yeah right
is super chill you go skiing there right
yeah i've been skiing in austria
um and snowballing in there and italy
mm-hmm
it's really nice just skiing in europe
or snowboarding in europe in general
it's like
it's super expensive but yeah i really
know i really want to do it it's really
nice yeah i really i just want to go to
europe mall
yeah everything's just super [ __ ]
expensive this is just like a travel
wish list now
this is just us fantasizing and covered
times yeah i'm just kidding
remember remember before covert existed
and we could
travel to places see my family
yeah i do want to go back home and visit
my family because it's weird because
this will be like the second
christmas in a row where i haven't seen
them which is normally would be the
thing where it's like okay i'll go back
for christmas
yeah you know um but yeah i mean that's
that's one big thing but as far as
living in japan goes and i mentioned
on like you know the quality of life
being really good here i
definitely felt like at least another
two years i want to stay here yeah and i
think it'll be a case of
in a year i'll know if it's gonna be
another two years it's one of those
things where i i'll just as it goes i'll
keep changing that number that's how it
is like from
like with a lot of my friends who are
from overseas who live here
or have been living here it's always the
case of you know all right we'll give
ourselves one more year
see how it goes and then usually like 90
of the time after that year ends up it's
like another year
and then it just keeps going right and
it's such a pain to move [ __ ] back it's
like
it's worth the like i really can't be
bothered with that again